foreign
[Music]
Tucson Arizona Tucson Arizona you're up
next Tucson Arizona and then I got some
dates in Colorado and Charlotte oh and I
just added uh Las Vegas to my website so
go check that out I'm gonna be doing uh
some Las Vegas dates
uh they're up now and then um also
Nashville coming up Little Rock Montreal
anyway
um so go to chrisley.com and uh
check out my tour tickets I'll be in uh
Cleveland and without further ado
this is the new episode of
congratulations
[Music]
and so I am off and running you know uh
it is Memorial Day today and we don't
stop just because it's a holiday and
people don't work on holidays doesn't
mean that we don't work on holidays
doesn't mean I don't work Hardy
on holidays we gotta bleep that out uh
too early to do a swear word we gotta we
gotta work hard we work hard dude I sit
here and I talk for an hour and there's
people out there doing stuff like you
know making buildings and manual labor
but they're not sitting here talking for
an hour
uh uh so talk about hard labor
um
yeah yeah I get it you know it's all
good people get me mad at that even
though it's a joke but it's fine you
know
um it is Memorial Day and I'll tell you
what my ears are clogged yes dude Myers
are clogged and am I am I sick no but
why are my ears clogged I have no idea
dude I'm not sick but I'm here's a clock
mayor's been clocked for three days and
that is just perfect and I'll tell you I
blew my nose
right before
the show right now made it worse dude
yes it made it worse so now I can hear
anything but it's all good I don't need
to hear anything because I can it's just
me right it's just me talking
um
I am it's been gloomy right a little
weather report here it's been gloomy by
the way speaking of report go check out
the tour reports man the last few have
been just absolutely banging the the
Cincinnati one particularly uh on my
other channel my crystalia channel on
YouTube
um and while you're at it leave a leave
a comment dude you're listening leave a
comment right now dude and get the
algorithm pump and make sure your your
um
your uh signed your uh subscribe to
super super good Studios uh yeah man
it's been gloomy and it's been dude the
weather affects me man the weather
affects me what's going on with this man
I pay premium rent
mortgage but I pay I pay a lot to live
here I I do you know the LA tax
I do the California tax
I pay a lot to live here
so stop with the greatness
I don't like that I don't like the
goodness I pay here to live the best
part about this place the weather now
was it
the vibe three years ago before covid
yes
and now is it way different enough to
see Ovid yes
so what's up what's the greatest reason
to live here because of the weather and
then we don't even have it right now at
this point
we're creeping on a come up on June here
right
so let's get it only sunny every single
day I don't like the grayness I don't
like the clouds clouds get out of here
I don't even know how people do it how
do people live in Detroit ah get out of
here I'll be there soon chrisley.com
how do people do it I only want to live
in a place where it's sunny every day
every single day I need to move to I
don't know where I need to move to where
where is it sunny every single day
Florida but then they got the storms and
the hurricanes and
so it's like all right I guess we settle
on what we do we come here we pay high
taxes for California and then guess what
the greatness it encapsulates us all
it envelops us all
so okay so then I guess we're just gonna
be sitting here in the greatness and
that's not that's not good that's not
good
but
um you know
I just don't I don't know but it's been
okay I've been kind of hanging out I
haven't really done many shows I did you
know last time I was on the road I did
uh Salt Lake which I just keep going
back to that was a really special show
and uh but I've been hanging out I've
been with my family William's getting
chunky how about that man
William's getting chunky my second born
getting chunky
I watch that show Silo forget it dude
it's so good I don't like shows that are
all the same color and there's so much
Brown in it but dude that show's so good
and that that woman Rebecca Ferguson
dude she's killer I love her I love
Rebecca Ferguson
I don't like the name Ferguson but uh I
love I don't really like the name
Rebecca either because
I don't like the name at all honestly
Rebecca Ferguson is a bad name
especially because Rebecca is a bad name
because you can also the nickname for it
is even worse Becky so Becca bad too so
she's all over the place with the name
but dude she's awesome she's very
beautiful and she's a very good actress
dude and I guess she's mentioned
impossible had no idea
but this move this show Silo on Apple TV
Dude said it and forget it it's so good
I love it
and I know I said it last episode but I
love it dude I think I said it on the
patreon episode actually go to
patreon.com crystalia sign up for the
extra patreon episode every month we
have about 30.
um yeah dude
it's such a good show and I watched it
and guess what I did I like this show so
much that guess what he did no don't
tell him no don't no tell him come on no
no guess what he did even though he
watched the show oh what'd he do Judy
went into the suggested shows after that
what the you you may also like well he
didn't know he'd know what he did and he
perused again is that all he did no no
no dude he clicked on what what oh he
clicked on one he started watching and
dude he took Apple TV suggestions he did
what get out of here dude he did me I
did and I clicked on the show Foundation
oh forget it dude I clicked on the show
Foundation how come they can make shows
that I didn't even know existed for
three years what dude nobody knows any
of the shows anymore I swear to God
dude I saw a billboard I was driving
down Sunset Boulevard I was driving I
saw a billboard for um
um uh
uh stranger things and it said
the one of will go down in history one
of the quotes will go down into history
as one of the greatest shows in in of
all time and I was just like dude hey
let's not act like people are gonna
forget about that show once it gets off
the air right
that show is and
now I'm not saying
I'm not saying good or bad I watched the
first season I'm and I'm like okay you
know that's what I do I watch that show
I go like this okay
everyone flips out about it I go like
this okay I know the actors in there are
good I know they do good jobs the story
whatever but I'm just like okay when I
watch that show okay
um
but
how can a show be on
they're doing a season two so it's not
that much of foundation but how did I
not know about it I I clicked on the
trailer of the show Foundation Apple TV
and I go like this let's take I go like
this okay now you know I side eye it
right because every TV show is trash
pretty much nowadays and every movie is
even more trash
but I don't really watch the movies I
watch the TV shows and sometimes I watch
the movies for fun and you know for [__]
to Giggles as jokes right because
there's really no good movies
so I watch
the trailer to the foundation and I go
oh I'm in I'm in why two things two
reasons why I'm in first of all
there's one actor I recognize and this
isn't one of the reasons why I'm in but
I got to talk about this first how are
you making a show
with the guy the only person I recognize
in the whole show with a crazy Ensemble
I mean this Ensemble is so insane it's
about a dystopian
let me ask you a question
how come
what's up with shows about the future
I would say 95 of the show is about the
future
the Technologies off the charts right
they can do they got like hover cars
and like
uh
wow I'm going on so many we I got so
many tentacles here I want to go back to
cover cars remind me about hover cars
Ivan but so why are there so many shows
about the future I'm talking about 95 of
the shows about the future
where the technology is off the charts
just crazy ridiculous but still
everyone's [__] dirty
like dude
you could just walk into a room and
think lights on the lights go boom
welcome Bartholomew because there's so
for some reason in 30 years everyone's
got weird [__] names right welcome
brother Dave you know
and you walk in and you go you think
lights on but still you're walking you
got [__] stains all over your face
you're dressed in rags
you look like Kanye West just got in
fight with a cheetah
like dude make the [__] clothing
biotech make the you know what I mean
make the clothing this [__] too
I got the incels barking because
someone's showing up the dogs are
barking but like why the [__] are the
shows so Bonkers rad and it's like ever
people like can literally see their
shopping list their grocery list on
their eyeball in the inside of their
eyeball they just go oh well we got to
go to the grocery store let's check out
what the girl what we need let's look at
the list I wrote and they just go
and then they go I want that I want that
I want that and then it just shows up
through a shoot from the grocery store
in the kitchen island all of a sudden
you got a jar of mayonnaise and some
Triscuits but they're still dirty as
[__] dude
and they like live underground and
figure all of it out so I don't like
about these dirty future shows
it should all be like Demolition Man
clean as [__] cool as [__] they are in
the tight outfits flying cars
here's the other thing I don't like
about
the Star Wars stuff and the and the all
this all the
this show the foundation hover cars
that's that is such a dated thing to
have on a show about the future dude if
there were gonna be hover cars there
would already be hover cars
hover cars are [__] and let me tell
you why okay because
dude they don't even they're not even
off the ground that they're off the
ground as much as you would have wheels
on a car
why do you need you don't need it if you
go make a flying car make the car go all
the way up around everywhere
the hope
that [__] [__] off with that
I don't like that have the car
either have wheels or it flies
completely
that's some [__] [__] hover cars just
in a dirty I gotta brush my teeth outfit
so I watched this show the foundation
because of two reasons all right now how
can you well this isn't it yet I'm not
going into the two reasons yet
how the [__] can you have a show
how the how
bro how much money do they have the
Apple I know they obviously have a lot
of money this show's got a cost It's
gotta cost eight million dollars an
episode okay
there's ten of them
say it's 80 million dollars say it's not
split that 40 million dollars five
million dollars to do each of these
shows
it's got to cost more but let's say it
costs 500 so 40 million dollars are
spending on this dude the only act and
there's so many actors in it
there's there's uh
this is how many characters are in it
dude it's about the future with
in a galaxy they're not just focused on
one planet they got like so many
different planets and actors on
different planets
so there's like a hundred [__] leads
in this show
and just like every show nowadays the
white people are bad right
and any any person of color is like a
hero no matter what
there was actually one person of color
in the show that did a terrorist
thing and I was like man they're gonna
get written up by Hollywood
so
how was the only person I recognize is
the [__] guy from uh Chernobyl the
show which is so Good by the way
and all that shows the same color too
it's all green I guess I like shows that
are all the same color even though I
thought I didn't
um
but so I'm watching this show and I
watch I watch a trailer and I go like
this am I gonna watch this and then I
see yeah I'm gonna watch it for two
reasons why because of the guy that sent
it he looks [__] radish [__] and when
you look that rad I watch a show
and the guy's name is Lee Pace okay now
let me look him up because Lee Pace now
this guy okay so look
I'm watching this [__] show because
of Lee Pace I don't know who this guy is
but I watch him because he's got he
looks like I've got a really angular
body and he looks shredded and I love it
and he looks like a guy he's got cool
long hair he's basically like a super
good looking version of me which kind of
sucks makes me feel insecure but dude
and I know he's tall because I can just
see it and I I'm like this guy this
sucks right this sucks and here's the
best looking kind of guy
the guy that looks like he would be dope
with a beard
that doesn't even have a beard this guy
is so handsome that he's like you know
what I get how I'd look with a beard I'm
actually not even gonna have one and
he's clean shaven he's so handsome that
that beard looks like it's trying to
come out right like he's got a it's not
even a five o'clock shadow it's like a 1
30.
right like he shave it's like 11 11 A.M
he's got just peeking out 11 A.M that
just wants to start bursting out they go
I know five o'clock hey at the 11 A.M
hair in there is like that's five
o'clock somewhere right
hey there's different time zones though
aren't they their hair trying to come
out just right trying to come out yeah
he's handsome let's make him more
handsome that's what we want we want to
procreate so I go like this
I'm gonna watch the show and he's got
the best outfit in the whole show it's
super blue and it's just all armor but
it's nice and like still thin but like
he can he's Mobile in it and it stops
right here so it shows his cuts and I'm
like I gotta get out to the gym more
which I've been doing by the way
but he's got just enough product in his
hair and I'm just like great thick
eyebrows just a good looking dude so I'm
like I'm gonna watch it because of him
because I don't recognize him so like
who's this guy he's a lead in one of the
show in the show that's cost 80 million
dollars and I'm just gonna I don't know
this guy come on
I watch that and then there's in the
trailer there's like not dragons but
like beasts in it so I'm like a Mullen
so those are the two reasons why I'm
watching the show when I say watch a
show
and I'm watching this show
this guy Lee Pace now I'm spending way
too much time talking about this show
foundation on Apple TV but it doesn't
matter dude because this is where you
come for the hard-hitting facts how
congratulations podcast is it of
this show
to talk about for 10 minutes a show
that's been on for two seasons already
not even good to talk about it but
that's what we do and the cult's with me
my babies
so
I'm watching the show and I find this
show is it's fine it's very hard to
understand because they just it's so
mathematical it's about
sounds so like something I would try to
like write when I was 15.
but like it's about a um uh uh uh
a scientist
um they call it like psycho mathematic
history or something anyway you can um
predict what happens in the future with
large populations because of math which
is
[__] stupid honestly but I'm watching
the show
and
so I find it's very hard to understand
like they start talking in all sorts of
jog it's almost like
make it a little bit simpler I'm a dumb
I'm a dumb dumb so let's get it going so
watch this [__] and I find myself
watching the show and every time this
Elite Pace guy comes on I go like this
yeah all right you know I get a little
in my feelings about it just watching
the show by the way by myself just
watching a show trying to understand the
show and like the show but also this
guy's
he's got he's got it going on too much
so I'm like okay so I watch another
episode
and I'm just stuck with how good looking
this guy is and also he's a good actor
and also he's British so I'm like all
right I gotta look this guy up [__]
It's gotta happen I gotta look the guy
up
so I look at who's on the show I see his
name is Lee Pace and I'm like
that name is kind of cool kinda so I'm
like [__]
this guy's cool he's got a cool name
so go to his Instagram
I look at his Instagram
he's got you know not a million
followers but a lot I find out okay he
was like one of the [__]
elves that nobody knew about in Lord of
the Rings or whatever the [__] I don't
know if his Lord of the Rings or yeah it
was Lord of the Rings
and I'm like all right okay so he's got
some cool rolls
and I'm looking through his Instagram
I'm like this [__] has a great
body
so now I'm getting more pissed off again
you can tell he's big
so now I'm like oh [__] and I see how he
looks with a beard
so I'm like this guy
he's really really he's working my last
nerve all right but I'm on his side
though
he's just it's unfair with how good
looking I think this dude is
and I'm like I wonder if Kristen would
[__] probably like this guy I go if
he has a beard probably [__] be all
in right
and then I Google him
and he pops up
and I'm like looking at certain pictures
and I know that probably people are
going to be upset that I you know I say
this
sometimes
you could look at pictures of people
and you're like just by the picture
you're like
is he gay
and then I Google easily Pace gay
Duty tied the knot with his husband last
year
foreign
so I go like this
wow
and immediately I don't feel threatened
anymore now how [__] up
how [__] up am I
I'm just watching a show
by the way I'm married he's
I don't know
I made this guy up in my head
practically
but I'm watching them
and uh now I'm like oh I love it I love
that he's gay because
even I don't have to worry about the
[__] anymore and I already don't
by the way
this is the [__] that deserves
an Emmy for this [__]
dude he's American
he's playing British I don't know first
of all I don't know he's not British on
the show the foundation second of all I
don't know he's gay
bro this dude is killer
how do I not know two things about you
they should this guy should work for the
[__] CIA
my favorite actor
Skyrocket
we pay Stan dude
anyway I gotta watch The Lord of the
Rings shows now because of him
um guys good dude I just want to smell
his breath you know
it's got to be great
talking entirely too much about this
show and him obviously somebody send
this to him let him know I'm a [__]
hugely paced fan
God if he was straight imagine but dude
good for him man good for him you know
good for him
God the guy's just so comfortable in his
skin huh that's the thing dude you got
to be comfortable in your skin
[__] you gotta be comfortable in your
skin
anyway the show's fine it's too
confusing for me
and I spend way too much time talking
about it but this is the hard-hitting
facts here dude speaking about going
working out dude because the guy's got a
great body that's one of the reasons why
I thought he was gay too if somebody's
super fit and that could look at him
like oh are they gay because you know
gay guys like to have be really fit or
really fat right there's no in between
gay dudes really
like I saw a gay dude the other day
walking around and I knew he was gay
because the way he was walking right was
like he was bigger but also he sometimes
gay guys with big stomachs walk walk
like proud about it with the tummy out
you know like they walk into a [__]
store in the tummy gets there like
0.0001 seconds before them I know that's
kind of true for all of us but these
guys tell me got in a little bit earlier
than my tummy would even get in right
um and he had a mid-drift or whatever
they fought crop top I don't know what
they call it but his tummy was just out
and it's like okay we get that you're
proud and you're working it but also get
a longer shirt or lose weight you know
right like don't be both
don't be that big and then also have a
crop top right because then I gotta be
like oh [__] ah now I'm thinking about
it you're infringing on my thoughts so
there's two types of gay guys the real
fat ones that like own it and then the
[__] super fit ones
um
so I go I now I go to the gym and I go
to the gym and you know that right
because speaking of Lord of the Rings
they need to [__] shoot the the
prequel TV show on my back right
and um
I did deadlifts
uh uh I've been using the hex bar but
dude I started doing the traditional
Olympic bar or whatever the [__] they
call it
you know and uh so that's about it it's
about it about that but uh
yeah I'm trying to get that Lee Pace
body I wonder how tall he is how tall is
I look it up how tall
I gotta look it up because of my not
because of my OCD but honestly
I want to look it up Lee Pace height
you
you got to be [__] you got to be
[__] me dude
he's six five
you gotta be
this guy is the best looking guy I've
ever seen in my life I I honestly he's
six I wish he wasn't gay I wish he was
out there
just destroying
hey babe
you're probably like a guy named Lee
Pace
come come in here for a sec
you like a guy probably
you could stay there but you're like a
guy probably
I'm watching this new show on foundation
on Apple TV and there's a guy on it and
you like him
well but I don't know if
you're gonna be on camera it's okay if
you are but
look
oh yeah well I liked him just the face
you like the face
all right
okay well he's gay
I know you can't have them
no he's not he's gay and it's beautiful
look at his husband Matthew Foley
well okay not all the good ones but so
you're straight as an
is it yeah look at him hi Calvin look at
him
look at him Calvin is that his husband
that's his husband who's also cool yeah
all right
anyway it could have been your father
Calvin
so he's so good looking dude and he
works out
he works out babe
he's so good looking look him up with a
beard
um
the whole [__] podcast about this guy
on my [__] notes I have
I I
barely ever take notes
on my notes I have handsome Foundation
guy
speaking of The Lord of the Rings uh
they did is Aragon from Lord of the
Rings he's black now did you know that
they made him black for the magic the
Gathering cards but by the way you can
have just
Lord of the Rings guys on Magic the
Gathering I don't know dude that's what
it said they made Aragon black and like
the the they're up in arms about it
wasn't it Vigo Mortensen who played him
yeah and now he's black so the
internet's going like is this okay would
Gerard Tolkien wanted that is that the
guy who did it jrk JK
are talking Tolkien read this him right
Jr Tolkien
uh
so uh that guy is black and I wonder
what JK jrk rowlings would have done
calling token would have done
because that's fine with me I don't give
a [__] he's an elf or whatever the [__]
make him I don't give a [__]
make him have a penis on their head I
don't care they're [__] elves they
don't know you know is Aragon an elf
what is Aragon
the king of many elves of man oh so he's
a guy oh he's a guy okay well he still
doesn't exist because it's Lord of the
Rings so I don't give a [__] make Batman
Green
um
just don't make [__] the the Shonda
Rhimes show woman is black you know in
history she was in history a white
person but I don't care
it's Netflix dude they're gonna have a
[__] paraplegic by Daredevil soon
uh
uh just blind and also in a wheelchair
can't move
stop evil doer people guys like No And
just [__] jumps away he says ah [__]
I don't even know I can't see or do [__]
really
and just
blow into the [__]
um so yeah Aragon's black so that's
what's up they painted them real nice
too like super handsome they painted
them real nice
like and uh
it's dope
and uh I'm like dude they're painting
them too real like they don't actually
exist you know I don't like when they
paint
people that don't exist too real well
I'm [__] crazy bro I because like
make him a little bit more cartoony they
don't actually exist
you're gonna pay them all real dude just
paint a guy because here's the thing one
day somebody's gonna [__] up paint a
fake guy so real that you're gonna
actually by mistake paint a real guy
and then that guy's gonna see it they're
gonna be like you painted me and you're
gonna get [__] sued that's my
likeness right black guy who's Aragon
Who in real life looks like garagons but
be like I want money from that magic the
Gathering pay me why is Magic the
Gathering in uh and having a lot of
rings people in it too many crossovers
right
won't be happy till Anne Franks and
X-Men
um
and Frank let's go [__] save the
world I can't I can't I gotta stay up
here
um
I don't like how Apple TV and and
Paramount Plus
they come out with shows they don't just
drop them like Netflix does they [__]
drop them they drop like three and you
get hooked on them and I know this is by
Design they try to do it and then they
[__] release it every week and I'm
like why do they do that and then
somebody said to me they do it to keep
you watching to keep you [__]
subscribed and I'm like oh [__] yeah
that's right
that annoys me that makes me want to
unsubscribe
I got my pure Spectrum gummies CBD
you can go to uh
the pure Spectrum thing what is it um
let's see what it is pure
Spectrum
uh the the CBDs
um
CBD I I go here peer Spectrum
cbd.com there it is
and you could click and you can get like
a big percent off by typing in
uh congrats congratulations or congrats
congrats you get 15 off on all your CBD
stuff I'm gonna take it right now I love
it all right take the gummies
be a spectrum
cbd's good
oh
that was loud
um
so anyway I'm chilling
oh
I guess there's hold on this is what I
wanted to watch
Dylan Mulvaney
likes
women now
this guy
is he I'm starting to get to like are
you is he trolling
us is he just trying to make some money
off the [__] I don't know man
thank you
I want to watch this
oh my God I have never felt so alive I
haven't really talked to you about this
but I have been followed on and off for
the past two months and usually I just
try to pretend it's not happening but
today it really bugged me and I was just
going to get my laser hair removal and I
was like in the office and I like walked
out and I was like I'm gonna lose them
and so I turned full-on Fast and Furious
Tokyo Drift and I'm like racing like
down Alleyways and like I felt like Liam
Neeson and like taken and I did it I
lost them it was so exciting but now I
do think I might be addicted to drag
racing and not the RuPaul kind
um but it's also just funny because I
think you know they were trying to get a
picture of me looking not great but I
feel great and I'm just gonna post
post what
it's on here so you know posting it for
free all right happy weekend I love you
protect your piece
I mean that was fine
um
these people in the thing please get
security if you can
yeah but also you know stay safe out
there you know people are [__]
um
crazy and I don't want you to die
so
let's chill
uh I I but yeah apparently people the
internet is up in arms because
uh Dylan uh uh is saying that
they're like uh
women now
or something
so it's like
how how long until
she's just like he she I don't know you
know I I don't want to [__]
Mulvaney
how long until Dylan
it wait what the [__] come on
it's just gonna be like oh I have to
sign in dude I don't have Twitter [__]
maybe I can do it on my phone
uh
uh dude Lonzo ball you know
Lonzo ball
is
uh about Lonzo ball sounds like oh here
it is Lonzo ball sounds like [__] uh
uh uh uh uh
game that would come out in the 90s that
like kids would play with
hey guys it's Lonzo ball
right
hey guys it's Lonzo ball you and your
friends up to eight can play grab a ball
and wait until the robot yells Lonzo
Lonzo ball and the robot Lonzo Lonzo
ball from Mattel
grab eight of your friends it's Lonzo
ball
yeah here it is
that I may be a little bit romantically
interested in women and
considering the past 10 years of coming
out as gay then queer the non-binary
then trans and I think it was just a bit
of a shock
so I tell my dad and he goes well I
would love to see you get a woman
pregnant and I said oh no no she would
be getting me so I recently told my
parents that I may be a little bit
that's the end of it well that's the end
of what I see right here my parents that
I may be a little gone by because well I
would love to see you get a woman
pregnant and I said oh no no she would
be kidding me
uh the end of that how does that happen
I think that this person is just uh
[__] with us huh you know what I mean
because it's like uh
I don't know
if the woman got him pregnant or her I
don't I don't even know anymore but if
that person Dylan got pregnant then I'm
in dude just do it get pregnant person
um and um that's great get pregnant I
want it I want it to be like I won't be
happy to like to remember that show the
movie Junior was that what it was with
John got pregnant we're like Danny
DeVito nutted in his [__] and then he
got a well I don't [__] remember how
it goes that's twins but um
okay
yeah Arnold Schwarzenegger got nutted in
but his his butt got nutted in and then
it [__] had a kid
um
yeah
uh the thing is some here's the and I
made a clip on there was a clip that
went viral that I was talking about how
I think this this dilemma veiny person
is not all mentally sound uh and not
because they claim to be trans but
because of how you can tell when
someone's crazy just by looking at them
and even hearing them really
um and I was saying this and then uh
here's another uh red flag on if
somebody is uh not well they are
constantly changing their uh identity
which is that that person is doing that
like this is why a lot of actors are
crazy actors will be like super Jiu
Jitsu and then yoga and then matcha like
all they know although just eat like
they'll eat vegan and then they'll be
like on a carnivore diet it's like like
Charlie Hunnam probably does that [__]
and he's [__] batshit crazy probably
and uh
I don't know if he does that but I'm
just saying like these people who
constantly change their identity are
[__] insane that's it and I don't
know I'm I don't give a [__] transnot go
ahead B whatever I don't give a [__]
I'm just saying that person sounds like
a loon not because they're trans
because they sound like a loon
um
so yeah
I don't know I guess you can be trans
and like women if you were born a guy
it's just all sorts of weird
also what about women dude women are
like man I've been a woman all my life
and it's [__] hard and I gotta deal
with this [__] and get periods and all
that now you're just gonna come along
and be the best woman of all time like
remember when Caitlyn Jenner was on the
cover of the thing women of the year
it's like dude if I was a woman I'd be
so [__] mad
then again who gave a moment of the Year
time or who gives a [__]
you know
I don't think it's a [__] about anything
is what it is
here's another thing about
look at this
this is the best I've seen this too
about this guy this guy is so so so
funny he's also probably trolling I
don't know maybe not but
so funny come on dude internet's not
good
oh is that it's that black dude who's
bald who has a really like dyed beard
the thing when he was talking about uh
he was talking about it with uh who's
the one who used to date Kanye West that
big uh asked girl Amber Rose uh when he
was like when she was like I'm a [__]
and he and he she was like it's okay to
be a [__] and he was like it's amazing
that you think that way
this is great why won't this play I'm
pissed
I'm gonna here we go
do you regret not getting married no
children or anything no do you regret
you're married having children now that
you're older
well and I'm gay you're gay yeah you
don't look gay
oh you know you come in all shapes and
sizes brother
so you okay oh wow I didn't know you
were gay yeah I mean I just told you how
did you become gay one doesn't become
gay one is born that way does God know
you're gay I believe so you know wow
this guy can you make you that way it
makes you that way my opinion you think
that God Made You Gay I have no you know
I I don't know the I'm not going to be
presumed to uh why would this guy go on
this guy's show you know you know what's
gonna happen Plumb the depths of the of
the most high but yes I've I've been gay
as long as I can remember and so have
you been with men of course like
sexually yes really yeah
all right
[Laughter]
this guy knows gay people exist you know
this is mind-blowing for you yeah is
that because I never expected a priest
and a father of Epiphany Church to be
gay that you're you know sounds like
you're coming from the Assumption what
what's look gay man you know a switch in
and soft looking really wow what do you
call stereotyping oh but it's called Uh
that's like if I were to say to you well
you're black where's your Fried Chicken
dude well he says [__] I don't say at
the house I can't wait to get home to
eat it
really that's what you call stereotyping
oh but it's called Uh that's like if I
were to say to you well you're black
where's your fried chicken I was at the
house I can't wait to get home to eat it
that's funny bro so you know that's
amazing are you does you do your
congregation know that you're exactly
they do
that is my blog and so you think that
God made mistakes
ah this guy's unbelievable dude this guy
really is unbelievable
um that's a big question
um
wow that is good talking about
everything that is that is involved at
the not only at the bottom of this
universe but whatever ever what other uh
whatever other inner universes exist
so I would say that um
how do you know I don't think actually
that force that we call God makes
mistakes no
dude
how about this is hilarious okay let me
tell you why no children or anything no
so this priest is gay
this guy can't believe he's gay
they're they're he's like I guess it
sounds like he's judgmental right
you know he sounds honestly just simple
but
they're both talking about God
and it's like okay but
we can go further and just not talk
about this because probably
there's no God do you know what I mean
probably there's no God because of how
honestly because for real because of the
Kardashians are here and I don't want to
that's not a
God really put them there on this planet
to test me and that's an egotistical
thing to say but
this guy's brain broke because of that
that's hilarious
you know what the guy's probably gay
right this guy I want to look at more
videos of this guy
it's called the Fallen state
is what it is
um
I've seen this guy the Fallen
state
uh
uh Amber Rose video
here we go
and it's like well if going out on a
date with a guy makes me a [__] then
that's just what I'm gonna be I don't
think going out on a date mate you're
slow having sex with different men makes
you makes you a [__] how does it make
you if you have sex with different women
a [__] maker
oh wow isn't that amazing no it's bad
but men shouldn't do that either though
it's not I know that a lot of women
think that
he says isn't that amazing like like
like like when he says it it's fact you
know once I made you slow you sleep with
a lot of women and then and then what's
that make you see a lot of women a [__]
maker and she said oh wow is it isn't
that amazing honestly that's how Calvin
talks hold on that men get away with
that right but they really don't a man
should not be having sex with different
women
oh okay
why not
it's not it doesn't show respect to the
woman
who wants it and then he should correct
her because the woman doesn't want sex
with different men but what's the
difference between a man and a woman
besides a private parts was it different
would you say what's really the
difference right
what is the difference we're both human
right so if I want to have sex
I should be able to happen I want to
have sex and I shouldn't be labeled as
anything because I'm a human being how
would you define US personally Define
[__] how do you there we go I I Define
it as a derogatory word that men and
women use against other women to put us
down for our sexuality and so you want
to take the shame out of that word so
that when women do these things they
won't feel embarrassed by it but it's
not about them doing these things that's
where you you that's where the mistake
comes in right so this guy just doesn't
give a [__] okay right because it's
really what people think about you it
doesn't matter actually what you do
right so like if you're in high school
and a boy goes and makes a rumor about
you that you did this that in the third
it doesn't mean you actually did it it's
what people think that's true so now
you're the school [__] that's true so
that is true regardless that's what I
mean you can be called a [__] and not
actually be a [__]
it's just a derogatory word that people
use to bully women to put them down for
what they either think they did or what
they actually did
preach
um
who is that guy
do you even know what his name is
n't that amazing that's so funny dude we
gotta watch that part again isn't that
amazing
then that's just what I'm gonna be I
don't think going out on a date mate you
a [__] but having sex with different men
makes you made you a [__] well what does
it make you if you have sex with
different women a [__] maker
a [__] maker
oh wow isn't that amazing
but men shouldn't do that either though
it's not I know that a lot of women
think that Jesse Lee what man is a that
men get away with that right dude this
guy
Savage moments are you a Christian I am
not you're not a Christian now and where
do you put yourself as
concerned a religion
maybe I'm multi-religious if that makes
sense no I
did
no is great this guy suffers no [__]
I am a person who believes in
faith and goodness holistically
amazing I've noticed that women today
not all not all but most of the liberal
women they seem to be they pretend to be
tough but yeah when you see these type
of movements they are saying that
they're weak you know they need laws and
they accuse men if that's though they
don't know how or have the strength to
say no to a man or to walk away whereas
when I was growing up women were
stronger and if if they didn't want to
do anything with you you knew it you
said okay fine you know I have a lot of
friends I think
um you know Trump has has do you think
that Trump sells lies blatant lies do
you see that the president is more
transparent than any president or
Administration in recent history no
absolutely not absolutely how is he not
transparent well why the video own up to
the Stormy Daniels story if he's
transparent that's a dumb man don't go
there I mean give me something that's a
question that's a personal thing give me
something and it's based in truth
somewhere and he just owned the truth of
it that's shallow I'm not going there
with you that's shallow give me
something but it speaks about his
character though what does that have to
do with the president
when he when his character is in
question how is he these characters not
in question I'm questioning his
character the piece of questions and he
hasn't answered and the reason you're
doing that because you are a member of
the family of the children of the LIE
are you Christians uh I believe in God
yeah
that said we're specifically what
he wants us to be I don't think he wants
to be called a Christian or Jewish or
Buddhist or anything he just he's not
supposed to believe in him are you a
Christian uh I believe in God yeah I
didn't ask that I asked are you a
Christian I believe in God you're not
going to answer that question well I
don't know what how I don't know what a
Christian is I grew up in Christian
church I'll tell you that but let me ask
are you a Christian so God dude a dog
with a bone no you
I
identify
like
uh
she's done a lot of harm Patrick are you
are you a Christian
are you a Christian I don't think so
you can't answer yes or no
I I'm not sure that's for me and God to
figure out once I mean God we'll figure
that out this is insane you realize you
sound insane right now right no
absolutely not absolutely not I told you
I grew up in a Christian Church
I know exactly what Christianity is
how do you know how do you know what
Christianity is when you don't know if
you're one or not well I'll tell
then you would know if you want or not
so it doesn't make sense I I then I'm
not I'll say I'm not you're not a
Christian why is that so hard to say
well because the reason I say that I'm
not is because I don't think I live up
to the parameters of what a really good
Christian when you see I should know if
you're one or not the answer
okay okay well he got to the bottom of
it uh that's amazing dude
holy [__]
this guy's amazing for some reason I
think he went viral again because
everyone's hitting me up saying you got
to talk about this guy uh are you a
Christian
I Christian I don't know I CR so David I
he is so [__] over every everyone
just just
SMA saying
so good uh God I would hang out with
that guy
um let's look at here we go
um
let's look at some some tenders okay oh
oh god a woman says to
another no to someone
come get that assate respectfully
mine respectfully would rather eat your
ass
oh sweet little man I can take care of
you love
and then I say I'm not sure you want to
I'm a hairy man
she says I want to enter the jungle
oh okay well
it's also all it takes all sorts right
takes all sorts of All Sorts well end of
the Jungle God that [__] just to be like
because you know there's like toilet
paper in here too a little bit with real
hairy dudes
not for me I'm just saying
maybe type it once or twice but I'm just
saying
that's actually so
eating a dude's butt is is gross you
know that's why gay guys are so hairless
because they know they get it
because they're a guy and they've eaten
butts that are also hairy and they're
like well I'm going to do my part and
just shave my you know Wax It Whatever
this is the [__] biggest clap back of
all time the guy the guys the girl says
the woman says all men are trash and
that's and then and then and the guy
says that's exactly why I only like
women
or is it so low
I don't know
um
he got her there huh hopefully I had a
date out of that one
pretty gangster to do that
okay uh
he unmatched pretty quickly okay here we
go
um
thoughts on 69
uh overrated she says three favorite sex
positions and why
she says my favorite position has got to
be one going on a date two holding hands
because we like each other and three
cutting on the couch and P just watching
TV amen sister I love it dude put him in
his place and they're my favorite
because they're really turn me on gives
me butterflies and [__] and the bonus
fourth I also secretly love is called
meeting the parents wow this guy got
he's got unfriended dude
that's good dude I think if a guy comes
like that that's how that's how the
woman should come you know good job
good job man good job well put me in my
place [__] five years ago 100 percent
here we go you might here we go you
might enjoy being choked but Turtles
don't pick up your [__] trash Oh Boy
and then he says six three what does it
even mean
Turtles don't do you know what that
means
oh don't litter
wow
I mean that's so so many got to do so
much thinking to like the people don't
want to be on these apps thinking you
know they just want to know if you have
a good face
um
here we go there's another one
what it says what's your favorite
medieval helmet you know such a dork and
then she writes all very good vintages
hope
but I'm afraid you run into a bit of a
medieval helmets connoisseur there is of
course no better helmet than the one
five one one horn helmet that was a gift
to King area the eighth from a Holy
Roman Emperor 5 11 was generally a great
year for helmets but the horn helmet is
the cream of the crop wow dude just did
a bit of Googling huh
that's good though she obviously liked
him that's good or they both love
helmets he probably [__] with her and
she'd probably [__] with him but if
they both have helmets dude they found
someone hopefully they wear a helmet
when they do the horizontal Mambo right
because you got to have safe sex
um all right you guys thank you very
much for watching the show talked about
that show foundation and that dudeley
pays for so long but you know what you
got to see a little bit of Kristen and
Calvin
um I appreciate you guys leave a comment
for the algorithm we love it and uh stay
tuned patreon.com
crystalia for the patreon that's it for
the episode on YouTube but uh go check
out the extra episodes in the uncut
version
um and uh and that's about it thanks
very much we appreciate you guys go
tickets to chrisley.com and there's also
that new merch out there the grow or die
merch christie.com thanks guys
[Music]
okay